what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are covering x-men red and uh
this is okay so this this comic is
actually really cool and I was unsure
about it in the beginning I was like
okay x-men read like an x-men team led
by Jean Grey but like she hasn't been
relevant for like ten years most one
because she's been dead and even before
then she wasn't really relevant about 15
years before then because there was
really nothing interesting about her it
was like okay let's give this a shot and
let's see what happens this is awesome
it really is like a blend between
classic x-men storytelling with with
like Chris Claremont and like Tom
Taylor's own style and it works
exceedingly well now a little bit of a
history here I wanna talk about this
were saying the reason why is called
x-men red is as a break from tradition
while maintaining picture a tradition at
the same time so originally the
chronology of the x-men was that you had
the x-men title by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby and then that was not very popular
and so that was canceled 60 some-odd
issues in and it was reprints for the
next thirty issues up to 93 did it was
relaunched with giant-size x-men number
one and then it was retitled to uncanny
x-men and it stayed that way for
seventeen years and so along the way the
original x-men roster of like beast and
Cyclops and Angel and Iceman and Jean
Grey
they were basically removed from from
the the uncanny x-men team and they were
thrown into their own book called
x-factor which proved to be incredibly
popular and so by the time we got into
the early 1990s both titles were
consolidated back down into a single
x-men roster and then the teams were
split in half one team was called x-men
gold one team was called x-men blue and
they were covered in x-men vol 2 and
uncanny x-men so there were two x-men
books running at the same time and so
from there having x-men read is designed
to play on the color schemes of the
x-men gold x-men blue but then like
introduced a third element the problem
with this is that it was obviously it's
obviously was meant to go on to be an
ongoing series but I assume that Marvel
cut its legs out from under it because
of the Fresh Start initiative and
they're rebooting uncanny x-men I'll or
I guess they're bringing back uncanny
x-men so all this is kind of
consolidating things down so imagine
what they did in the early 1990s
condensed down like 11 issues kind of
just bringing it all together so in any
event this initially opens up with like
some young girl they see like a girl
named Heather who's essentially like has
her whole like her house just broken
into and attacked by people in the local
neighborhood and they're mean it's
literally just like unrivaled and kind
of insane because they just unload on
this girl right but of course this leads
to Jean Grey jumping in and basically
blocking the blocking the shots and then
of course you have Nightcrawler and you
have x-23 who jump in as well now one
thing I also want to mention here is
that this story comes after
xmin red annual number one which kind of
creates the missing link between gene
gray after the events of Phoenix
resurrection and the start of this the
problem is that that has like a huge
spoiler for what goes on in this story
so I don't really want to I don't really
want to squirrel that too much probably
introduce that in a different time
because it's just like a one or two page
reveal they kind of gives everything
away but this goes into the introduction
of a handful of interesting characters I
mean you have basically Jean Grey you've
got gentle you've got Namor who's
brought onto the team you've got honey
badger in x-23 those are guys who aren't
reading x-23 honey badger was like one
of the clones of of x-23 basically and
in the old man Logan universe the idea
seemed to be that like honey badger
killed x-23 so again it's SEO at least
in the old man Logan universe once it's
kind of a murky situation but regardless
this is like the x-men red team and of
course we'll get some information on how
each one of these characters was brought
in but this is a non running theme that
Tom Taylor hits out you know he kind of
jumps back two months before the X the
x-men red team shows up to rescue
Heather and it's just like this mass and
like this this in a huge and insane
instance of just like all around
violence like violence is just
increasing at an exponential scale and
it's kind of bonkers to see it to see it
happen because when these guys show up
on this woman's car she's got a mutant
in the backseat and of course the mutant
basically has like a sonic scream now
it's not like black bolts quasi sonic
screen right like that is one of the
things that I kind of hope you guys
notice here like it basically lets off
kind of like this explosive this is
explosive impact or at least a blow to
the car then and so on but the nature of
the scream is very much like the like
Black Bolt scream and because Marvel's
running death of the Inhumans at the
moment or at least just finished with
issue number five but because they were
doing death of the Inhumans it kind of
makes sense they would take that and
like roll it over to the extra because
that's one of the things we're gonna see
here new x-men are gonna be popping up
they're gonna have powers that are
equivalent to existing characters so
it's kind of like making the extra in
their own again but he end up having
Jean Grey in them who rescue the baby of
course returns to the mom and they say
look you didn't go into hiding you could
do your own thing like we basically put
a dampener into your maybe won't cry so
much which is kind of weird because how
in the hell else is a baby gonna tell us
mom when it's hungry it's just gonna sit
there and starve but uh but the fact
remains this switches over to kind of a
news broadcast now the way this news
broadcast unfolds is very akin to
something that we would see back to her
in the days of like my project wide
awake ordering like extinction agenda
the idea was when Claremont and even
people after him Scott Liddell and so on
whenever they were telling x-men stories
and they were trying to maintain like
the real world element in terms of like
you know telling more of a soap opera
than just like a traditional superhero
story you would see news clips that were
thrown in there and it was designed to
give you a well-rounded
standing of like how the world viewed
the x-men that it wasn't just like oh
you know these guys are kind of
dangerous it was how like the whole
world saw them and that's really what
goes on here then you have people who
are just kinda like hey look they're
just meeting sir they can't control what
they are then you have others who say it
doesn't matter you know just because a
man's a psychopath with a mission
deficiency he can't control it doesn't
mean that we just let him on the streets
for free you know we lock him up I mean
is there's some some pretty intense
arguments that are raging back and forth
that if they can't help what they do
then they should be treated like they
can't help what they do and in turn
imprisonment but that's kind of the
nature of the way the x-men arguments
have always been but what is up
happening is you have this really really
cool idea from Jean Grey where she
basically goes around to like these
various ambassadors or world leaders it
says look I need all of your help and
she even goes to Black Panther now with
Black Panther
there's an olive branch here because
remember back her in the days of Civil
War and even leading up to Civil War
Black Panther and storm of the x-men had
to have a relationship you know and
really they met his children was one of
the things that Marvel had introduced
later on down the line but they met his
kids and in the early days they kind of
had like this this infatuation with each
other because they were really too young
to be in love but officially they ran
back into each other again and then
eventually got married now of course my
Panther nullified the marriage he was
just like the high priest of hands are
cold nullifies our marriage and she's
like he's there's nothing I could do
about it she's like but aren't you like
the high priest and he's like bye and
they just leave it was kind of the
crappiest way to nullify a marriage but
still like like that's the olive branch
is being brought in here and so
basically her you know going to to like
go to to Nightcrawler and showing him
what her vision is to kind of brain and
bring about this peaceful coexistence
it's a lot more middle-of-the-road than
what Xavier would do right I mean okay
so so on one side you had Xavier who was
like just you know talk reason you know
and all that kind of stuff just like
basically be a hippie like if we fight
the good fight and we do the right thing
the nut dildo agree with us you know we
have to take the upper hand and Cyclops
is like okay so like if that worked it
would have worked by now so like it
doesn't work so now we got to take a
heavy hand he was far more extreme by
the time he became leader of the x-men
going into like the post house of am
post decimation and like nation X utopia
going in like all those stories he
became a lot more extreme he was pretty
heavy-handed and so Jean Grey kind of
has this middle-of-the-road where she's
like it's not enough to just kind of sit
around hoping things change but it's a
little too heavy-handed to be extreme
like we can't force people to change
instead we kind of have to throw it in
their face and that's what she does Jean
Grey travels to the United Nations and
basically says look here's how things
stand here if your concern is that
somehow I could use my powers to swindle
you that I could trick all of you guys
and Alou into one
think that's entirely true I could do
that I could have done that three miles
away like I could have I could have done
that almost anywhere on the planet but
I'm not because I'm not here to control
you I'm here to talk to you and to give
you guys a better understanding of what
mutants are and where we're coming from
right now like we are essentially a
society unto ourselves we are culture
unto ourselves and we are a quote
unquote Empire Kingdom nation unto
ourselves and as such we want to be seen
as one now this is a big move because
Xavier never would have done this and so
while there is a lot of posturing before
she have Namor who stands up and says
the kingdom of Atlantis recognizes the
nation immunised where you have like
Panther who stands up and says the
kingdom of Wakanda recognized ization ax
mutants while people do know the
connection they do have to the x-men it
works you know and so you of course you
have like the chick from Britain who
comes out and she's like look you know
all that in there is posture I do it for
the cameras really because I have to but
at the end of the day I'm on your side
and it's kind of cool here because as
this chick starts to talk to Jean this
is where the story shift as this chick
starts to talk to Jean suddenly her
demeanor changes and she says but the
one problem here Jean is that you are
not in control and you never worry
you're not the Phoenix anymore you're
just Jean Grey which means you are
powerless in the face of me and then and
like as Jean Grey kind of analyzes
chicks MA she realizes there's somebody
in there
like there's somebody in the mind of
this woman controlling her and then this
chick basically blows up this woman's
head whoever's like running this three
oh this is her chat district said
explodes and whoever's running like
who's controlling this woman basically
kills her but it looks like Jean Grey
doesn't because Jean Grey reaches out
for eight and at the moment that happens
this girl's head explodes
and so everybody who looked at that says
Jean Grey just killed a sitting world
leader and that's what we end up finding
out the person who's pulling the strings
here the person who's behind all this is
Cassandra Nova now that is not a small
thing and a lot of people like a lot
people weren't really familiar with the
extra know kind of like who the hell's
Cassandra Nova all right there are all
manner of dangerous villains out there
for the x-men right you have Magneto and
you have like mr. sinister and you've
got apocalypse if you got a mega red a
mega red depending on the circumstances
you've got you've got a lot of
characters out there who were very very
dangerous among all of these is
Cassandra Nova and depending on what
story you're reading either she's uh
she's part of the mummer die which
basically means like she's a different
but she's a different race she's like
one of these ancient beings that's out
there or she was the sister of Xavier
who is a Xavier absorbed into himself
but her consciousness remained launched
but the the general principle behind
this though is that Cassandra Nova is
exceedingly dangerous she's going on
like a warpath against mutants the first
time she did this was during a is for
extinction and she took a whole bunch of
wild Sentinel
she sent him all to Genosha an island
full of mutants and massacred 16 million
of them she's a wildly powerful telepath
when she sets her mind to it she could
be nigh unstoppable and that seems to be
what's going on here that Cassandra Nova
by whatever manner and whatever means
it's basically pushing the world towards
greater hatred towards itself and
towards a mutant population now from
here we pick up with gene grain company
who are basically sit like this super
codec message that comes from a chick
named trinary and we end up finding out
that like trinary is basically a
technopath now in Marvel Comics there's
a difference between a technopath
and a cyber path a technopath is a
mutant that has the ability by virtue of
their own mutant power to tap into
various technological systems computer
systems all kinds of stuff AI so on and
so forth and then just like manipulate
it to their own ends a cyber path is
basically a non mutant who can do the
same thing the differs is that usually
cyber paths are people who are super
smart with computers so like in like
Tony Stark or other people who by virtue
of some enhancement like cable can tap
into computer systems like Ultron can do
that because he's basically a living
machine but again like a telepath is
kind of a way to say like the powers are
basically the same but a mutant versus a
non mutant is really what it is like
omega-level mutant versus Omega level
threats at the end of the day they're
all the same thing it's just one group
of mutant in one group isn't so again
it's kind of a cool little a cool little
bit here but trinary is basically being
held in india because her father turned
her in which is pretty shady but the
other thing about this and this is kind
of a cool moment there get this guy
named lac shea who's basically like the
the head Oh like these various forces
intelligence group that's keeping
keeping trinary hidden it's kind of a
cool thing here this is one of the cool
things I miss about like telepaths in an
x-men comics is what they do is is this
guy's on his way to getting coffee and
so what they do is Jean Grey basically
warps his perception of the world so the
guy makes a left into an alleyway and
believes he's ordering coffee while he's
in there it's a small thing but it's
cool and it's one of the things that I
kind of miss and then Jean Grey scans
his mind and uses that as a way to know
what all what the layouts gonna be who's
where who's doing what all that kind of
cool stuff you know it's one of the
things that you don't really see anymore
so of course you know Nightcrawler
teleports in grabs her you know and then
and then teleports now and again this
leads to like the rise of this mob and
so it's basically this this ongoing
theme that like Cassandra Nova knows
what Jean Grey is doing and while she
could stop her while she could just like
jump in her way and just unleash
absolute hell on Jean Grey and probably
take her down at the end of the day she
doesn't but it is kind of a weird
situation because Jean Grey is still
wildly powerful and in the old new x-men
stories it was shown that she was a
little more
I think you a more powerful than
Cassandra Nova it gets weird when you
get down to that because there was so
much metaphor like there were so many
metaphors there's so much symbolism
because it's grand mores and
storytelling and nobody in the he'll
ever understand of the hill Grant
Morrison saying when he tells stories I
mean Hellfire just tell a regular story
Grant Morrison's but uh but nonetheless
you know it is kind of cool you know
with like this whole mob showing up you
know and just kind of unleashing on
things because for the x-men it's really
more about damage control right I mean
the x-men could fight them if they
wanted to but all that would do is make
things look worse because from the
perception of the world Jean Grey killed
killed a world leader so we would just
look worse and worse and worse and so
what you end up having is you end up
having the signal protocol that's
initiated by this intelligence group in
the in the government which leads to
like this signal attacking them well of
course they've got a technopath
so this battle is really really really
fast and basically trinary take just
settle down and it is kind of like okay
like this signals down and is now
essentially reprogrammed and that's it
but basically the excerpt are kind of
like okay we need to get out of here as
soon as possible because we don't need
these things coming after us over and
over and over again and so in the midst
of all this like it's kind of a cool
thing you end up transitioning all the
way out to Louisiana and a lot of like
you guys are gonna be happy about this
you transition out to Louisiana there's
one girl who's being attacked nothing
too special about her but in the midst
of this whole attack one of the guys
basically hit like somebody steals a
stick from one of these guys one of the
flame sticks and it's gambit which means
gambits basically returning now like
gambits finally showing back up in the
excavating universe really after you
know some of the more recent event and
is basically going on - like rejoin the
x-men team which again is kind of like
this consolidation that x-men red is
serving the purpose of consolidating all
these mutant themes and bringing things
back to the way they were before which
is cool now while all that was going on
with regards to gambit and and Jean Grey
and so on and so forth Cassandra Nova
had basically slipped into the Xavier
Institute had gone to to storm and then
put something in her ear and that in
turn led to the x-men returning to
Wakanda and then stormed his unleashing
hell and taking out their similar now
the initial response to this is okay
well maybe storm all she saw was like a
sentinel approaching from a distance and
it's like okay well obviously storm
would freak out an attack because it's a
signal the things are bred to kill
mutants what we end up finding out here
is that even when jean grey analyzes her
mind she basically says this is not
storm like this is storm but something's
controlling storm and so in turn like
you have black panther that tries to
reason with her everybody tries to
reason with her and it doesn't work and
so this leads to basically this
character gentle who's essentially the
Incredible Hulk like is that he
literally grows in size his strain
increases basically a mutant version The
Incredible Hulk
who does what he can try to stand in the
way of storm but of course again like
he's taken
like so many other people and this leads
to Jean Grey basically like attacking
the mind of storm and in doing so like
basically incapacitating her for a time
and that's what we end up finding out
here that what's going on with with
regard to storm herself is that while it
is Cassandra Nova involving herself with
storm it's not really telepathy it's not
mental control
instead what Cassandra Nova did wasn't
planned a kind of nano device in the
mind of storm and this is actually super
genius this is super smart because if
gets it let's say for example Cassandra
Nova decided to sit down and like a
recreated cerebrum and say okay I'm
going to assault the world then what
this does is it creates a singular
source to defeat all the x-men have to
do is go to the singular source of
contact Cassandra Nova de fée Cassandra
Nova and that's it but instead what
Cassandra's done here is she's created
an army of billions which means the
x-men have to defeat each and every one
individual person by taking this device
away from the brain it's one of the
smartest things to do but that's kind of
the question that's being asked here is
the technology required to create
something like this is highly advanced
like someone out there has to be
creating these things and so that's when
we end up having like a Sandra Nova who
basically starts traveling around to
like these different locations to Europe
to Africa to North America to Asia
starts traveling like all these world
leaders and basically saying like I
present you with a thing and then
basically like introducing this nano
device into them and then turning them
into like rabid anti-mutant individuals
now some that something else that I hope
you guys notice here is this something
that I hope you guys are beginning to
pick up they can say it her nose is not
alone she's not by herself she's met
there with a third party this third
party looks like Forge and that would
make perfect sense as to why it is that
she's able to pull all this off for
those of you guys who were unfamiliar
with Forge Forge is like imagine Tony
Stark like imagine imagine somebody
being equally as intelligent as Tony
Stark when it comes to engineering the
difference between Forge and Tony Stark
is that forges knowledge of like
machinery and in complex components like
engineering or so on that's his power if
you were to take away forges power he'd
be no more capable of assembling
advanced pieces of machinery they're
like just some average Joe walking down
the street so having said that he can
invent a wide array of different things
his knowledge is to just know how things
work to intuitively know how things work
so that's why things are kind of crazy
is because you end up having the x-men
sort of running back into gambit again
when you know they all kind of meet at
this hospital of this guy who shot this
girl and you know again what was first
introduced and so on but when when the
x-men do show up gambits their butt
doesn't fully know what's going on all
he knows is like this giant Sentinel
just manifests in front of him and
that's when he really begins to freak
out you know when the x-men grab and
they pick him up Missy okay let's go
they teleport him back and there's this
giant signal standing there gambit panic
gorge again that makes sense mean that's
one thing to bear in mind guys when it
comes to the action because of how
intense the sentinels have been over the
years the signals have always just been
like this terrifying ominous thing
because they're sort of like this
walking talking representation of like
the death a mutant kind and so for a lot
of mutants out there it's established
PTSD fortunately for gambit this
Sentinels not dangerous and why is it
not dangerous because it's painted
because it looks pretty which of course
was done by honey badger which is kind
of cool I think it's adorable
like I think I think it's cute like they
named it and everything they put like a
big rainbow and everything is like it's
a nice signal but one of the big things
that's been going on here with us and
Renova basically implanting these nano
devices in the ears of these world
leaders it's not really just like hey
let's just kill everyone what it is is
it's basically them like tracking down
and annihilating mutants in their own in
their own countries in their own places
and so again it's basically Cassandra
Nova by virtue of her telepathy
alongside these nano devices pushing
humanity ever closer towards Haiti
mutants and then in their hatred of
mutants passing laws to eliminate
mutants like imagine Days of Future past
unlike a much broader scale unlike a
worldwide scale but with Jean Grey
showing up with Jean Grey basically like
facing off against all these guys what
she does is kind of override their minds
and say look you need to actually see
what's going on here not only that at
the same time that happens named where
the Submariner shows up and basically
says you guys are touching water and if
you're touching water you're touching my
kingdom you're touching my domain so
either you can back off or I'll
eradicate every last one of you and so
because of the fact that the x-men
aren't really welcome look will they can
go to a condo but it's not really a safe
place anymore because Atlantis hasn't
been compromised yet basically name of
the Submariner opens the doors up and
says you guys are welcome to take up
refuge here and that's basically what
ends up happening the end of taking
refuge in Atlantis they end up residing
there and at this point it's just
remarking their forces and see if they
can't find a way to take out the forces
of Cassandra Nova to somehow fix
humanity to somehow fix these various
government government officials and to
see if there's a way to even salvage
everything after it's all been said and
done in reality I would say this is
probably more akin to like the the
Sommers rebellion for the guys who don't
know the character bishop comes from a
future which is almost identical to the
Days of Future past the difference is
that they had the Summers rebellion
which was basically mutants and humans
working together to cast off the
Sentinel threat when that happened
following that there was an uneasy truce
between humans immunes and that may be
what ends up going on here and what it
does is it basically removes
the government and the average group of
people from the equation a minute gives
room for Tom Taylor to bring in bring
back like the purifiers and to bring
back you know the friends of humanity
and the bring back that right and all
those guys and to say fine if the
governments of the world aren't going to
take these guys on did it we'll do it
then we'll we'll find a way to eliminate
means kind of setting things back to the
status quo of how mutants are the x-men
used to be in like the 80's 90's in the
early 2000s but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here too comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the wrong for
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
you